la elección del solvente puede tener un
efecto en un mecanismo sn 1 o sn 2
empecemos con los solventes polares
prácticos un solvente polar práctico es
un solvente que tiene al menos un
hidrógeno unido a un átomo electro
negativo por ejemplo si analizamos el
agua podemos ver que tenemos un
hidrógeno unido directamente a un átomo
electro negativo que en este caso es el
oxígeno entonces el agua es un excelente
ejemplo de un solvente polar pro tico
después tenemos metanol que nuevamente
tiene un hidrógeno unido directamente a
un átomo electro negativo el oxígeno y
finalmente tenemos ácido acético en el
que tenemos la misma situación aquí está
nuestro hidrógeno y éste es nuestro
oxígeno así que con un solvente polar
práctico se favorece el mecanismo s en
eeuu no veamos porque aquí abajo tenemos
bromuro de éter butilo y para un
mecanismo
1 el primer paso es la pérdida del grupo
saliente entonces estos electrones se
van junto con el bromo para formar
nuestra unión bromuro y también vamos a
formar un carbó catión entonces primero
dibujemos el carbó catión aquí tenemos
un carbono que está unido a tres grupos
metilo y este es un carbó catión plano y
el carbono tiene una carga formal
positiva y también tenemos el bromo que
ya tenía tres pares de electrones libres
se los ponemos pero ahora tiene otro par
de electrones libres que estaban en este
enlace entonces esos electrones que he
resaltado de color rosa se van junto con
el bromo y eso le da una carga formal
negativa este es el año en bromuro
entonces mediante el mecanismo sn uno
obtenemos este kart vocación y este año
y sabemos que este paso es decir la
pérdida del grupo saliente es el paso
determinante de la velocidad del
mecanismo sn 1 y si usamos un solvente
polar práctico como el agua podemos
estabilizar tanto al kart vocación como
a la unión por ejemplo en nuestro carbó
catión sabemos que el carbono tiene una
carga positiva y si observamos el agua
sabemos que este oxígeno tiene una carga
parcial negativa porque el oxígeno es
más electro negativo que el hidrógeno y
este hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva entonces la parte negativa de
esta molécula el oxígeno interactúa con
el carbono cargado positivamente del
carbó catión mostremos una molécula de
agua por aquí ok y en este oxígeno
tenemos una carga parcial negativa con
dos pares de electrones libres así
estabilizamos el carbó catión y con el
año bromuro como está cargado
negativamente vamos a necesitar la otra
terminal de la molécula de agua entonces
si dibujamos la molécula de
tenemos dos pares de electrones libres
en el oxígeno y uno de los hidrógenos
que tiene una carga parcial positiva
interactúa con él a nyon para
estabilizarlo por eso los solventes
polares pro ticos nos ayudan a
estabilizar tanto al kart vocación como
a la unión y esas all but acción ayuda a
que el mecanismo s en eeuu no pueda
ocurrir por eso es que un solvente polar
práctico favorece el mecanismo sn 1
ahora veamos los solventes polares apro
ticos primero analicemos el dimetil
sulfona sido comúnmente conocido como
tms o porque aquí tenemos de m&s yo
ahora como el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el azufre el oxígeno retira
densidad electrónica así que tiene una
carga parcial negativa y por lo tanto el
azufre tiene una carga parcial positiva
y miren un solvente polar apro tico no
tiene un hidrógeno unido
directamente al átomo electro negativo
entonces si pensamos en los hidrógenos
del tms o aquí tenemos tres hidrógenos y
aquí también tenemos tres hidrógenos en
este carbono ok
aquí tenemos a los hidrógenos unidos
directamente al carbono pero el carbono
no es muy electro negativo por eso este
es un solvente polar a pro tico ok ahora
veamos la dimetil formamida conocida
como de mf para abreviar nuevamente no
tenemos un hidrógeno unido directamente
al átomo electro negativo porque miren
este hidrógeno está unido directamente a
este carbono y en este carbono tenemos 3
hidrógenos y después en este carbono
también tenemos 3 hidrógenos así que la
de mf es un solvente polar a pro tico y
finalmente veamos este ejemplo su
abreviación es hmt por la palabra
fósforo en inglés
y lo escribiré aquí abajo h&m
y nuevamente no tenemos ningún hidrógeno
unido directamente al átomo electro
negativo así que los solventes polares
apro ticos favorecen los mecanismos sn 2
veamos por qué aquí abajo tenemos una
reacción s n 2 del lado izquierdo
tenemos este al 1 del kilo o también
llamado halogenuro de alquilo y
supongamos que tenemos hidróxido de
sodio y de ms o como solvente y sabemos
que en un mecanismo s n 2 el núcleo fi
lo ataca al alumno de alquilo al mismo
tiempo que se va el grupo saliente
entonces en este caso nuestro núcleo
filo es el ión hidróxido y ataca a este
carbono al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones se van junto con el bromo
para formar el año en bromuro y así es
como el h reemplaza al bromo en nuestro
producto
ahora en un mecanismo sn 2 necesitamos
un núcleo filo fuerte para que pueda
atacar al alumno de alquilo y en este
caso el de ms o nos ayudará a
incrementar el efecto del núcleo filo es
decir de lyon hidróxido veamos cómo es
que nos ayuda
nosotros tenemos hidróxido de sodio
entonces primero vamos a concentrarnos
en el cut ión de sodio que lo tenemos
aquí y el de ms o es un buen soldador de
cationes y eso es porque el oxígeno
tiene una carga parcial negativa y el
azufre tiene una carga parcial positiva
y este par de electrones libres en el
oxígeno nos ayudan a estabilizar la
carga positiva del sodio y lo mismo por
acá parcial negativo y parcial positivo
y nuevamente sol batamos el catión
entonces el hecho de que un solvente
polar apro tico sea un buen sol bateador
del camión nos puede ayudar a separar
este ión de nuestro núcleo filo y eso
aumenta el efecto de lyon hidróxido
porque el ión hidróxido no es solo atado
por el solvente polar apro tico y tal
vez piense ok el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y el azufre es parcialmente
positivo entonces el azufre parcialmente
positivo puede interactuar con nuestro
núcleo filo cargado negativamente pero
recuerden que tenemos estos grupos
metilo voluminosos hay impedimento
histérico y eso evita que el ión
hidróxido interactúe con el dms o
entonces el guión hidróxido se queda
solo y eso incrementa su efecto como
núcleo filo con lo que será más fácil
que pueda atacar a la luz de alquiló y
si ahora usamos algo como el agua
sabemos que el agua es un solvente polar
práctico el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y los hidrógenos son
parcialmente positivos entonces un
solvente polar si puede interactuar con
el núcleo filo y soltarlo con lo que
disminuye
el efecto del núcleo filo por eso los
solventes polares prácticos no se
recomiendan en un mecanismo sn 2
mientras que un solvente polar apro tico
si aumenta el efecto del núcleo filo
favoreciendo el mecanismo sn 2